vamos a pensar en el diagrama de playoff
como si fuéramos propietarios o
pudiéramos ver a lo largo de la acción
desde la posesión es decir si pensamos
en el valor del subyacente estaríamos
hablando hasta la fecha de vencimiento
como sabemos tradicionalmente hablamos
de algún punto de vencimiento en la
opción pero este es el valor al
vencimiento con alguna fecha que tenemos
en mente olvidando sólo el valor si en
la fecha el precio de subyacente es 50
el valor de mantener la acción va a ser
de 50 después si el valor del precio de
subyacente es 0 entonces el valor de
tenerlo va a ser cero si el precio de
subyacente 70 el valor de tenerlo será
70 y obtenemos esta simple línea es
simplemente cualquier precio de
subyacente que es el valor de la ciudad
sólo seríamos dueños del almacén y ahora
si lo vemos desde un punto de vista de
pérdidas y ganancias en ese día estarías
pagando 50 dólares como primer tenedor
de aquí cualquier día que pongamos como
fecha de vencimiento por algún tipo de
opción estaríamos pagando 50 dólares por
cualquier tipo de opción y aquí
tendríamos el punto de equilibrio
si el valor es cero habrías perdido 50
dólares
tendríamos 50 negativo justo aquí si el
valor del precio pactado en esta fecha
tiende a 60 70 80 90 ó 100 tú solamente
habrás hecho 50 dólares que va a ser
este punto de aquí y tu ganancia será de
50 en el diagrama de periodo fluye más o
menos así una vez más la única
diferencia entre estos dos diagramas
planos es que justo este de aquí se
desplaza 50 unidades hacia abajo para
referir el precio que pagaste por
obtener el contrato ahora déjame decirte
qué pasa si sólo compras las acciones en
el precio pactado que quieres pero
deseas eliminar el riesgo que hay de
tenía algo negativo comprarás un seguro
con el precio pactado podrías comprar
una opción put con precio pactado de 50
para prevenir la baja si el precio va
por debajo de los 50 dólares y haces
esto lo único que haríamos en este
diagrama sería desplazar esto como
nosotros quisiéramos realmente que
luciera será simplemente el diagrama de
un putt que ya lo hemos hecho
anteriormente en un vídeo previo luce
como a continuación en este caso si el
precio
está por arriba del precio pactado no
vale la pena ejercerlo pues tendríamos
cero no conviene vender algo que en
realidad cuesta más caro más barato en
el putt nos conviene que el precio baje
baje del precio pactado para poderlo
vender en algo más caro pero qué pasa si
estás en ambos casos de ser así tal vez
en esta fecha en su presente vale cero
pero la opción vale 50 y la combinación
hace que tengamos 50 dólares si el
precio estuviera en 25 nuestra opción
put valdría 25 entonces si tenemos tanto
el subyacente como la opción put las
combinaciones van a ser 50 si el precio
está en 50 las opciones put valdrán 0
pero tú con la combinación esto valdrá
50 por lo que el precio de la acción le
dará el plus que parece como un pie en
el diagrama lucirá así el diagrama de
playoff que está justo aquí por lo que
observando lo que pasaría si todos los
precios de la acción se van por arriba
de 50 dólares hemos creado una especie
de guitarra ayudando a la d
y esto de aquí es el precio stock más el
plus del pus actuando como un seguro
usualmente a esto se refiere la gente
cuando hablan de comprar un seguro desde
una posición si nosotros dibujamos la
misma gráfica habremos desplazado hacia
abajo por la cantidad pactada más los 10
dólares que pagamos por el contratos que
es lo pactado más el costo de entrar en
esta posición